[Musique]
ce jeune homme commence sa journée des
étudiants elle va être une véritable
course contre la montre un plan d'action
ne sera pas inutile
il a choisi les sciences la france
manque de scientifiques et pour étudier
les sciences à paris en 1957 il faut
absolument savoir couilles
pourquoi courir parce qu'on doit arriver
tôt à la sorbonne si l'on veut avoir une
place au premier cours et même est il
question de place assise heureux ceux
qui peuvent simplement s'infiltrer dans
un amphi terre celui de géologie c'est
un exemple comporte 180 places et ils
sont 500 sur la plaque qui évoque le
professeur esclangon mort victime
d'instruments venus les travaux
pratiques offrent un autre spectacle
navrant comment travaille à l'aise dans
ces conditions
le drame c'est qu'il n'est même pas
possible que tous les cours soient
données à la sorbonne notre étudiant
reprend dans sa course vers un autre
coin du quartier
il faudra aussi courir au restaurant
universitaire et là une demi-heure
datant de forcer pour remettre en ordre
des notes qui en ont besoin
d'après midi nous retrouvons notre
étudiant en route pour la rue cuvier
nouveaux courts nouvelle destination
ainsi s'explique que la foule des
étudiants en sciences se soient
retrouvées à la sorbonne pour manifeste
manifestations pacifiques ou derrière
leur recteur leur doyen leurs
professeurs ils se sont efforcé
d'attirer l'attention sur la misère de
leurs facultés que demande tire que
l'emplacement de la halle aux vins
depuis si longtemps promis soit enfin
affecté à l'université puisque bercy est
assez grand pour reloger les chefs ils
ont en pris symboliquement possession à
l'heure où le pays manque de chimistes
d'ingénieurs de physiciens la faculté
des sciences de paris affiche raté
longtemps encore par deux places
[Musique]